[Music]
hey everyone welcome diller instalments
of Harry Potter theory in this video
were going to be discussing JK Rowling
the Goblet of Fire and the chapter that
took her 13 attempts I am of course
talking about chapter 9 the dark mark
given that JK Rowling had written
several books up to this point it's a
neutral she would suddenly just get
stuck it has been reported to this
chapter alone took Rowling 13 tries
which is honestly just adding insult to
injury given that she already had to
rewrite a good portion of the Goblet of
Fire
to remove a character among other things
if you want to know more about that
check out the video titled JK Rowling's
huge flaw with Goblet of Fire 13 times
can you imagine rewriting something 13
times a whole chapter that's the type of
thing that would make you want to throw
your computer off the balcony in an
interview Rowling even express it in
sidered just giving up at this point
sometimes even at this stage you can see
trouble looming nearly all of the six
published books of her chapters of doom
the quintessential never I hope to be
beaten chapter that nearly broke my will
to go on was chapter 9 copper to fire
appropriately enough the dark mark
she was also asked how many rough copies
or rewrites of a chapter do you do
before you get it right loads and loads
and loads the worst ever was 13
different versions of one chapter I
hated that chapter so much at one point
I thought of missing it out altogether
and just putting in a page saying
chapter 9 was too difficult going
straight to chapter 10 but fortunately
for us by the time Rowling got to
chapter 9 of book 4 she'd already
introduced the world to Harry Potter by
this point she had known with the choice
the show would have to go on but the
question stands why did this particular
chapter cause Rowling so much trouble
we were already so far into the Harry
Potter series what happened the reason
that chapter 9 was so difficult was
because it was the chapter that kicked
off the plot for the Goblet of Fire
this was the chapter that could make or
break the interest of the reader and
there was a lot going on it was in this
chapter that Barty Crouch jr. breaks
loose and begins to work on its Mars
so turn from the shadows he escapes
steals Harry's wand and then fires a
dark mark into the sky calling the Death
Eaters but all of this had to be done
without giving way too many clues to an
attentive reader
JK Rowling later discusses the chapter
with screenwriter Steve cloves who
worked on the Goblet of Fire that story
a must have spent three or four months
trying to make dramatically
comprehensible on-screen I am so sorry
and every time I did it you know
everyone you know I'm so sorry Steve
because I've handed you a problem that
had tortured me because the scene in the
Quidditch World Cup we first see but
don't see party crouch and you don't
know what's going on and the dark mark
appears of the first time and it's
incredibly obscure in every sense what's
going on there and trying to make that
appear in any way coherent to the reader
while obscuring as much as I wanted to
obscure was terrible at about thirteen
drafts about that chapter and that's it
for this video I hope you enjoyed it
leave a comment down below with your
favorite of the Harry Potter books until
next time you're a wizard Larry
[Music]